so a little later in today's show we're
going to talk about the 2022 midterm
outlook kind of looking into the 2024
election outlook there's some
interesting things going on already
interesting polling interesting betting
numbers and a lot of different things
the context in which this happening is a
in which this is happening is a series
of increasingly unhinged candidates
many of them supported by the failed
former president donald trump and one
such um example of what we're seeing we
saw this weekend as donald trump flew up
to anchorage alaska to hold a rally
really just in opposition to lisa
murkowski lisa murkowski is the current
alaska senator she is a republican but
she is a republican that is not
particularly a deferential to donald
trump and if that's the case trump
doesn't like you and trump will try to
get you booted out of office and that's
exactly what donald trump did in alaska
he also had uh sarah palin former vice
presidential candidate and current
congressional candidate sarah palin
speak at the event we're going to look
at it i will tell you many of these
clips are extraordinarily disturbing in
how stupid they indicate the country has
gotten now one of the things donald
trump did is he used the f word and it's
very cool i guess when you're a
republican to use the f word even if
you're a presidential candidate or a
former president even though the
republican party claims to be the party
of civility and moral values and
pro-family and christianity and
godliness and decency and character they
love the f-bomb and just imagine as you
watch and listen to this clip how would
they have reacted if barack obama had
dropped an f-bomb in a speech i mean
remember once barack obama
didn't wear a suit jacket in the oval
office and they went bonkers once barack
obama put his feet up on the desk in the
oval office and they said this is such a
disgrace and here it it's very different
here they cheer it and they love it
hit him on the left i'd hit him on the
right
i'd hit him in the center
that's pretty cool right when the
president swears it's very relatable and
he's a man of the people and all of this
stuff now maybe the epitome of the cult
moment we've we've talked many times
this is a cult
there's no question that this is the
cult they deify trump in a way that is
completely cult-like but this is maybe
the epitome
starting with a glitch trump tried to
start his conclusion which he always
does by saying in conclusion
and he almost said in collusion he
glitched very badly one of these brain
glitches and in order to cover it he
immediately aborted the teleprompter
read and started talking about a couple
or it might be a son and it might be a
mother and son or it might be a couple i
i genuinely can't tell what it is um
he who were wearing shirts that have
trump's face all over them he talked
about how he wants their shirt and they
i guess he was kind of kidding but they
quite literally took their shirts off
these are the shirts they wore they took
them off to give the shirt to trump so
this all starts with trump glitching
badly on in conclusion and it goes
downhill very quickly and look at the
cultish nature of this
include
i love this guy's shirt i tell you you
know i'd love to have you get up here
come on get up here let me see get up
here get this guy up here
come here i love this guy any guy wears
a shirt like that how can you not love
him look at that beautiful yeah would
you help him up
taylor help him up come on you're a
strong guy come here i just wanted and
you'll notice that as these people come
up they they look visibly disoriented by
what's going on
i like that one
[Music]
i want this shirt i'm going to wear it
to the next rally
[Applause]
now you and i can tell that's a joke but
they end up taking their shirts off
[Music]
i want it
[Applause]
and honestly if you're only listening
you're probably better off because the
cringe in what we're seeing here is
bizarre
[Applause]
thank you i want that shirt all right so
moments later they actually did take
their shirts off and we have an image of
these individuals and the image has not
been photoshopped they uh they took
their shirts off and it is the epitome
the epitome of the cult moment back to
some uh more substantial things donald
trump is now afraid to even use the word
vaccine this is very interesting in this
next clip donald trump tries to take
credit for the things he did during the
pandemic and one of the things trump
loves to take credit for is the vaccine
he doesn't actually say the word he says
we did it much faster than they said we
would but he doesn't say vaccine because
his audience is so anti-vaxx we did a
hell of a job never got credit for that
more people died under biden you saw
that
and the job we did with kovador as some
people call it to be more accurate the
china virus
but we did so much in terms of
therapeutics and a word that i'm not
allowed to mention but i'm still proud
of that word
he's he's not allowed to mention it but
he's proud of it because we did it we
did that
we did that in nine months and it was
supposed to take five years to 12 years
nobody else could have done it but i'm
not mentioning it in front of my people
but that's interesting he's he's
conceding if he uses the word vaccine in
front of his people they will boo
but that thing that thing
we did in months instead of years
another moment this is a classic trump
always trying to be relatable so he will
mention places in the state where he's
speaking here he says let's go to inside
passage the slopes of
denali
to the waters of glacier bay that's our
beautiful place
and from the forests of the interior to
the majestic vistas of
the inside passage does anybody know the
inside passage
anybody want to go there tonight right
beautiful name the inside let's go to
the inside passage tonight right you can
tell trump really familiar with the
state of alaska based on that um a
number of verbal misfires here he
referred to
the uh newest supreme court justice
katanji brown jackson as kachenji
she voted to approve joe biden's radical
left justice
kachengi
brown
jackson the most far left
justice in history the arguably the most
qualified justice in history another
misfire just a very glitchy evening for
trump trump trying to say elon musk and
he says leon and it all goes downhill
i tell you what
elon
elon right is not gonna buy twitter
where did you hear that before
leon's i tell you what
leon and then lastly now a staple of
these rallies the overt crass
transphobic portion of the speech
we will also keep men
out of
women's sports
major issues
[Applause]
right
the swimmer
the young swimmer she wanted to break
that record 1 16 of a second she was
going to do it
and she looked over and she said hello
to people that she's grown up with she's
seen him she's a top top swimmer she
looks left and she sees them hi hi you
know they hate each other but they're
you know they're competing hi hi they
hate her
she hates them that's the way life goes
right
then she looks over waves and then she
sees this
guy
they they say i mean this is supposed be
a technically
correct here a person with a man's body
okay it's a man's body
so they seized this person with a man's
body and he's a giant he's that big
guy's wingspan
i'm not even going to do the rest of it
because it's so overtly crass and
horrifying but that is now a staple of
these events so alaska a rally in alaska
everything going horribly wrong
and then it became sarah palin's
opportunity to speak and let's talk
about that next let's talk about vpn's
virtual private networks even if you're
using incognito mode on your browser if
you're not using a vpn everything you do
online can be recorded by your internet
provider and that is permanent because
they're selling it search engines social
media companies are also tracking your
every move you only need one thing to
protect yourself from all of it private
internet access one of our sponsors it's
a vpn it's simple you take a moment and
you download it you turn it on and
you're protected and you stay protected
and that's it vpns can also keep your
connection secure from hackers important
every time you check your bank account
or 401k or pension otherwise it can all
be out in the open private internet
access never records or stores user data
they've even proven this policy multiple
times in court their software is open
source to show that there's no data
being logged
this transparency is why private
internet access
is the vpn i use and my audience gets
eighty-two percent off so you can stay
protected for just two dollars and
eleven cents a month plus you'll get
three months free go to private internet
access dot com slash pacman the link is
down below